[Music]
so we have some new information tonight
about the possibility of the clark
county school district returning kids to
the classroom
eight news now reporter kristen drummond
is live in our newsroom tonight with the
latest for us
hi there hey denise the district sent a
survey to families last week
now this questionnaire is the first step
in one of many plans
to figure out this transition plan to a
hybrid model that's when students attend
school
two days a week and continue distance
education at home for the other three
days
now the survey has four questions
families can choose
which option works better for their
student either hybrid
or full-time distance education the
other questions on there deal with
transportation logistics the answers
will help ccsd form a transition plan
and
gives schools an idea of how many
students may return to campus
the board of trustees do plan to
consider a hybrid model on thursday
no details yet are public or at least
our public and posted on
their website but a principal offers me
some insight
about the possible high school day from
what i'm understanding is that
physically the students would be here in
the morning
and then the remainder of the day they
would be at home
attending school virtually in the
afternoon after after lunch
the survey reveals students may be
assigned to different teachers once the
hybrid model is in place
now if a family chooses full-time
distance education the student
may be required to continue doing that
the remainder of the school year
depending on available space in
classrooms and schools so something for
all families to consider
now the deadline to fill out the survey
is tonight if you're unable to
access it online you're encouraged to
call your child's school to let staff
know
your preference back to you